[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and my good friend ryan nicodemus is out
today he has a children's cold and so we
brought a special guest in the studio
you're going to see him in a moment but
first
let's talk about our culture we live in
a culture that's obsessed with
positivity and purpose
and so we've been told that nihilism is
perhaps the worst possible outcome for
humans but is that true is nihilism
always bad today on the public podcast
we're speaking with the philosopher he's
our fan favorite peter rollins is here
today we're talking about the nuances of
nihilism then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast peter and i
are going to talk about depression
despair suicidal thoughts and suffering
you can find that long-form conversation
at patreon.com
the minimalists there you'll also gain
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives your support keeps our podcast
and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
well peter before we get into our first
question today
i really got to say you truly are a fan
favorite so thank you for being on the
podcast you're just buttering me up
because i know that i was not the first
choice for today i know that the the
email came in a few days earlier
so you can butter me up as much as you
want it is true like he lives in los
angeles that we can get last minute who
who doesn't have a life
he'll be able to do it
i i've been wanting to have this
conversation about nihilism for a long
time in fact the day we're recording
this is the 11 year anniversary of the
minimalist and that first month in
december of 2010 we put up a
post about well the nihilism of fight
club and how it may or may not be
nihilism
and and so i want to talk to you a bit
about that i want to talk about what
does it even mean to be nihilist is it
necessarily bad and i want to talk about
all these other emotions as well because
you're right we originally were supposed
to have a different guest on today julie
wilson was supposed to be here she had
to reschedule we were going to talk
about suicide and suicidal thoughts so i
thought we would approximate that
conversation today with something that
often leads to despair to suffering to
misery and so let's dive into our
questions this is a listener driven show
sarah from facebook has a question for
us
can you explain the relationship between
nihilism and minimalism in a clear
tangible way
well i don't know if it'll be clear and
tangible
but you're the perfect guest to talk
about this because you do
you understand the nuances here and so
when we talk about minimalism there's
obviously all these different movements
of minimalism there's minimalist art
minimalist literature
when we're talking about minerals we're
talking about minimalism as a lifestyle
understanding what is essential for you
and it's highly individual
and then also eliminating the excess so
that's basically what we're talking
about with respect to living a simple
life or living as a minimalist and so
how would that apply to nihilism can we
even talk about what what is nihilism
because i think there are various
conceptions and misconceptions yeah i
mean
interestingly so minimalism the word
minimal means like less or little and
nihilism comes from the latin word nihil
meaning nil and meaning nothing so there
is an interesting
etymological connection between a
minimal lifestyle and the word nihilism
but there are issues there's lots of
differences and whatnot so maybe
will i start by giving a very basic
background to nihilism and that'll
probably get us somewhere
yeah so i mean at a very basic level
nihilism is about nothing right so if
you had a if you had a deity not for
nihilists it would be for people who
have nothing in common right because
people who like nothing and um
interestingly in philosophy
nothing has been a central topic right
from the beginning on in religion and
also in mathematics i mean it was a huge
development in mathematics when we
circled nothing and created zero i mean
that was a massive innovation for math
we also have
buddhism and hinduism various notions of
the nothing so this this idea of
nothingness
has
kind of attracted thinking
for thousands of years
but primarily when we use the word
nihilism we're referring to
something that really grew in the 18th
and 19th century and then
embedded itself in the 20th century
and
connected with that as the movement of
existentialism so interestingly
existentialism and nihilism are very
interconnected um as well as interesting
christianity so we'll kind of maybe see
the link between nihilism
existentialism and christianity
um but that's not really answering the
question about where it connects with
minimalism
um
i think about tyler durden in
fight club
and you know it's funny i saw that film
when i was probably in my late teens i'm
40 now and i remember watching again
around
age
30 and reading the book in my mid-20s
the book is much more sardonic than the
film
and
it's almost like this erotic
exaggeration of what one might call
nihilism or you could call it like
anarcho-primitivism there there's some
there's something there
when you think about the main character
who spoiler alert is schizophrenic and
essentially it manifests it's almost
like
buddhism manifesting in toxic
masculinity
is maybe the way i would describe the
film but there's a deep understanding of
all of the things we're attempting to do
do with our lives the activities the
actions the consumption the consumerism
is making us miserable there's no
inherent meaning in those things and so
when we're talking about nihilism
sometimes we're talking about
the
well the nothing is inherently
meaningful it's not that everything is
meaningless necessarily that can be one
interpretation but maybe there isn't an
inherent purpose or meaning to anything
yeah no that's true and bringing fight
club into it's very good point um so if
we take one of the primary uh
night here's the funny things you you
know we think of someone like nietzsche
as a nihilist but he actually wasn't he
was uh most thinkers that we think are
nihilists are attempting to overcome
nihilism but they take it very seriously
so for nietzsche
nihilism and he tells it the death of
god i'd love to explore what that phrase
means in a minute but he talks about
this experience of the death of god
and
one way of describing what he means
is an experience in which the way that
you
make sense of your life begins to
collapse so in fight club this guy who's
you know got a job he's buying all the
furniture he's trying to get the perfect
life
and then he experiences this
kind of sense of meaninglessness that
all of that fades away this is um
you can be experienced or called on
experience of the death of god
and nietzsche argues that we are in a
nihilistic world
and that we have to experience that loss
in order to create something better so
we have to kind of experience the loss
of meaning
in order to have the courage to enter
into something else and so fight club's
very much like that and even you know
the story that you've told me about your
life and the start of the minimalists
it was a type of death of god experience
where all of the way that you were
creating meaning in your life
suddenly became meaningless you
experienced the the
the lack of potency and it all dissolved
away and then you set yourself on a new
course
so for someone like nietzsche
we are human beings have this ability to
experience almost like a short circuit
like putting your finger into your
socket short circuiting yourself and and
reimagining the world
and getting yourself onto your new track
of cause and effect so the death of god
or the nihilistic event
is the event in which all of the ways
morally and materialistically you've
constructed your life
it all dissolves away and you have this
radical moment of freedom
yeah so
there's a line in fight club in the book
at least where he talks about the losing
all hope was freedom
and that's another word that we hope we
think of as always good and more we
moralize everything so it's always good
or bad it's binary and
nihilism bad hope good
but
the things that we hope for often drive
us toward misery unhappiness discontent
and ultimately despair suffering
a lot of a lot of that has to do with
the expectations we set and you
mentioned my story yeah it was very much
like the the narrator in fight club
where it you know i didn't devolve into
schizophrenia thankfully but this is
where i tell you that ryan doesn't exist
i don't know if they've told you this
yet but he's just a figment of your
imagination that's why he looks so messy
and you look so clean it's like your
opposites it is ordering chaos yeah and
i often wonder whether or not he is by
tyler durden yeah and
the the funny thing here is
yes there was actually never meaning in
the things i thought i would find
meaning in you know oh if i just buy the
right car oops that didn't work because
i didn't i bought the wrong car i needed
a fancier one a better one a second one
whatever it was materialism right you
know there's the sort of the thing in
fight club where it's he's essentially
an ikea catalog his house is
and it's not that there's anything
inherently wrong with ikea
the problem is the pers thinking the
pursuit of that is going to complete me
in fact there's even a line in the book
where he talks about i was almost
complete right in his apartment sort of
it burns down right and and he's
mourning that loss of
all being almost complete yes it's a
story he's telling himself yeah
yeah absolutely and
nietzsche has this very subtle way of
describing this experience so if you
look at the 20th century as the um
the the birth of nihilism as an attitude
and as an aesthetic
one of the most defining events was the
first world war so the first world war
was very significant in the kind of the
development of a nihilistic
um experience
now the subtlety of nietzsche
is that he says that the 20th century is
the denial of this experience of
nihilism and what he means by that is if
you think about it in terms of
fundamentalism people think the
fundamentalism is certainty right so if
you're a fundamentalist you have
certainty you have belief
but it's not quite like that so
something like paul tillick would say
that
when you're young you think you're right
because obviously you've never thought
about anything else and you just think
you're correct and your parents knew
everything that's not fundamentalism but
at a certain point in your life you then
confront someone who thinks differently
and who's smart who's intelligent he
gives you a different view
now at this point you've got two options
one option is to listen and go i've
never thought about that and you know go
with it or the other is to close your
ears say i'm not listening and then to
kind of retreat into your own little
castle and buy all your apologetics
books and try to defend against this
so fundamentalism isn't knowing it's
repressed or knowing it's it's a it's a
repressed disbelief and that's why you
can tell
if someone gets angry whenever you
disagree with them it's not because they
disagree with you it's because they
disagree with themselves there's
something they disagree with in
themselves that's coming out right
so in a similar way wait expand on that
a bit more so anger because i i find
anger arising in me
all the time and it's fascinating that
it doesn't manifest differently maybe
it's sadness
it could very well
but why anger in particular it doesn't
mean that i i react on it outwardly but
i can see it arising yes
and it's often has to do with the
expectations i place on myself or on
others exactly and so it's always a good
tale i i'm a big believer in
listening to
whenever we feel certain things so for
example if you're married
and someone says to you oh i don't think
marriage really works and i think you
know marge is like it's just going to
end up and even the happiest marriage
the best you can hope for sleeping in
separate rooms and silently hitting each
other right that's uh but there's going
to be affairs or whatever and someone
says that to you
if you get angry really angry and
frustrated there's probably a part of
you that agrees with them no you don't
know that consciously but but if you if
you just laugh and go oh yeah maybe
you're right maybe you're wrong right
and you don't have an affect that shows
that you're probably quite confident in
your marriage but if it generates this
anger i never want to see you again
um it's just like if i say to you i
think your partner's having an affair
and you get really angry with me and you
say get out of my house i never want to
see you again
that's evidence that you already know
what you just do want to know that you
knew it because instead of going oh my
goodness is that right and sitting down
and thinking about it and going oh i
don't that's i'm this is completely new
to me
the anger
is a sign that potentially you're
repressing the truth like all the signs
are there you just don't want to see it
almost like getting a letter from the
banker from a doctor and as long as you
don't open up you don't know that you've
got the heart disease or you've got you
know you're withdrawn you kind of know
what but you can't open the letter
because you do want to know that you
know it
we do want to be confronted with the
things that we know
and and so what nature says tweet that
podcast sean oh yeah i mean it's the
biggest thing is like the most radical
knowledge is not the stuff we don't know
but the stuff that we know but we do
want to know that we know so even yeah
[Laughter]
oh it's so true expand on that yeah like
so take a political example if you have
um well you know if you if someone is a
whistleblower and they say stuff that
you don't know that's a surprise but
generally the whistleblowers who get in
the most trouble are not the ones who
tell us what we don't know they tell us
what we do you know right say the
military are killing innocent people
we're being there's uh there's uh
surveillance technologies being used
against citizens we all know that stuff
we just do want to know that we know so
when a whistleblower comes out with the
evidence we're confronted with our
disavowed knowledge right it's the same
even like i do i i want to look at you
know uh leaflets about how they treat
animals and uh abattoirs
what because i don't know how they treat
them of course i know it's terrible i
just do want to know that i know because
if i know that i know then it will
disrupt my lifestyle and i have to make
a change right but if i can deny myself
so um slavyo shizek uses a funny example
from donald rumsfeld where if you
remember he once said there are things
that we
don't know
um there are things that we don't know
we don't know
and then he said there are things that
we know we don't know right this is a
famous kind of philosophy of rumsfeld
and what he meant is there's things that
we don't know right you know how many
cars are outside right now right there's
things that we don't know that we don't
know which is like certain weapons that
a country might have that we can't even
conceive of yes and then he says and
things that we we know we don't know
um that are things that we don't know
oh yes yeah things that we kind of like
we know they've got certain things we
don't know what but in terms of
psychoanalysis there's a fourth one and
the fourth one is things that we know
but we do want to know that we know and
that's that's the realm of the
unconscious
and so if i bring it back to to fight
club for a second the the real nihilism
there in a way
was the capitalists
and
when you see it manifest that way
because
we look for meaning we don't find
the meaning and so we keep sort of we
often throw our hands up and we just
settle for
misery or worse we settle for happiness
yes in some ways and we we um like a
great example of what what i was meaning
is that in the 20th century most people
today don't believe that having the
right apartment or the right car the
right this or that's going to make them
happy right they they don't believe it
but they still act as if they believe it
they believe it and i've heard you talk
about this because advertisers still
believe it that's right it's kind of the
belief through through the other and
just like uh
parents might not believe in santa claus
but they get all the enjoyment of the
belief because their child believes in
santa claus and it's only when the child
stops believing that that that affects
their experience of christmas yes the
death of santa death of santa yeah so
this weird thing about and this is why
by the way nietzsche used this beautiful
quote he said after
after the buddha died he said it was
said that the shadow of the buddha
remained on the cave wall for thousands
of years
he said
we must not only see the death of god we
must see the death of the shadow of god
and what he meant by that
was that actually
in the 20th century people have
experienced a loss of meaning they have
experienced a loss of external
authorities that will tell us what to do
and how to act we've experienced that
loss
however we deny that loss so we weirdly
more frantically go into materialism
more frantically go into fanaticism when
we're we're more we're actually in
danger of embracing hollow materialist
and fanaticist positions
precisely because we don't believe in
them that's that's why i use the
fundamentalist examples fundamentalism
is precisely
a certainty that portrays uncertainty
and so today there's a certain
fanaticism and materialism that actually
betrays
a disbelief that it works but but a
disbelief that we haven't embraced and
so for someone like paul tillich is we
have to have the courage
to
know what we know which is the courage
to embrace nihilism not so that we
despair but so that we can move beyond
despair yes yeah i do want to talk to
you so much more about despair but let's
move on to matt's question here on
facebook
is nihilism the same thing as pessimism
so
let's talk about specifically when we're
talking about
nihilism i think people conflate it with
pessimism
oh you're just a pessimist you're just a
nihilist they use the the terms
interchangeably yeah and it's i'm not
here to be a dictionary for you and so
if you mean the same thing but i'm not
going to get upset by that
matt but
it seems to me that these are two
unique
points of view in the world yeah
yeah and both by the way weirdly again
this is a bit
at first but strangely connected to
um
a belief
in something perfect so to take the
example of the pessimist if you're
depressed that your life hasn't worked
out and you've got a pessimistic view
it's because in some kind or factual way
in some possible world you're imagining
that you could have been happy
so weirdly
um you're in the world saying like
things aren't working out life is
terrible it's awful
what i will find
is maybe some relationship that you wish
had worked out or some job you wish
you'd taken something where you
fantasy that in some other world it
would be great and that's what feeds
pessimism whenever you realize that all
of life has a certain struggle and
trauma within it so there's no kind of
like perfect life you could have had
weirdly you overcome pessimism so so in
other words if you're depressed the way
to get over depression is to be more
depressed right the problem is we're not
depressed enough we're not pessimistic
enough this is the nietzschean idea of
nihilism is only overcome when you fully
enter into nihilism right um paul
tillich in a beautiful book called the
courage to be says that meaninglessness
the experience that life has no meaning
is not something to fight it's not
something to set up a wall against he
says what you have to do is you go into
that darkness you go into the dark night
of the soul into that cloud of unknowing
into the heart of that darkness and he
says and when you do that you will find
the way out it's like an escape room
where the only way out is to go deeper
in yeah and so we use these signifiers
like meaning and meaninglessness
but in doing that quite often you find
great meaning on the other side of it
not because it's intrinsic to whatever
you're doing but because you realize
you're assigning meaning to the things
that happen to be
your values what's important to you
perhaps yes
we have a question here from joshua
boggs on facebook
what would lead one to become a nihilist
why even strive to be successful in your
own life if it is meaningless anyway
yeah so so
peter the
the question here presupposes that one
should strive to be quote successful
and i can tell you by from following
that recipe and talking to tens of
thousands of people who have followed
that recipe yeah they've all baked the
same cake yes yes and it's misery yes
the striving is often the thing
that makes us miserable the idea of
success at least traditional cultural
success which is usually metric or goal
based
is something else that often makes us
miserable so
what would lead one to become annihilus
is often
it's in the question here success yes
and the drive for success right
absolutely so there's a weird movement
where
when you're successful like really
successful say in your field you become
a famous actor you get that money what
you discover is there is a failure
within that success i you get to the
mountaintop and you're like is that it
and
that's not eve that's not even
anecdotally we can talk about that but
like yourself and we're like this
constantly happens you watch people who
if they think that
that getting their goal is going to work
it it is existentially devastating but
however the next step is the success and
failure
so the failure and success is when you
you you go for what you want and you
realize it doesn't work but then if you
go into that failure the idea is that
that opens up to a different a mode of
success so in some respects i think we
all have to go through this this is why
nietzsche said we all have to go through
the death of god right because he says
we we kind of all have to expect whether
it's a broken relationship the death of
someone we love um a
feel you're in work or ill health
whatever it is an event
that kind of
makes everything turn to to vapor and
dust
is kind of like a moment where we can
really enter into a new mood of being
something even better but we have to
kind of go into it and so sometimes it's
actually the people who strive the most
or the ones who then fall into nihilism
and then go through nihilism and then
find this new way of being on the other
side of that
yeah and there seems to be so many
examples of this in
all the ancient wisdom traditions
whether it's christianity hinduism
buddhism can we talk about some of the
the connections there yeah and this is
called dialectics and philosophy and you
discover it which is if if i give you
two options
generally we try to choose the best
option so if if you know um
you've got a
light and dark you choose light either
narrow path a wide path you choose the
white path whatever now when you say we
try to choose the the better option
it's perspectival but it's not always
the best option according to us it could
be what our culture has dictated for us
our programming absolutely our
programming but even at the very base
level if i give you the option of
happiness or sadness you're you know
we're naturally going to go for
happiness right that's a very natural
thing oh i've got happiness and sadness
in front of me but
in dialectics the idea is actually um
you've got to choose the worst so if you
go to a proper psychoanalyst and you say
to them oh you know i i'm i'm feeling
depressed you know i want to get rid of
that depressed i want to get rid of the
darkness the analyst actually brings you
right into the heart of it they go like
actually in order to overcome the
darkness you have to go into light in
order to find life you have to die in
order to find a wide path you have to go
walk the narrow path so dialectics is
this really counter-intuitive thing that
because i see this in instagram and
stuff where people talk about you know i
i want to surround myself with
positivity right but usually that's a
sign of depression for me to survive
depression right that they're they're
having to affirm which is a nice thing
to do you're firm and things are good i
look in the mirror every day and i say
you're going to do it pete you're
beautiful you can accomplish everything
and you know that can make me feel
better briefly but the really sad and
difficult thing is
the dialectic of actually i have to face
the darkness i have to face the part of
me that i'm trying always to avoid with
these affirmations
and then then you go into the darkness
the nihilism then this is what what i
call that the nihilistic heart of
conversion
conversion is this moment of radical
death
that then allows for a resurrection a
new mood of being that that is yeah
anyway yeah we get into that's by the
way the death of god i keep coming back
to this phrase because nietzsche used it
and i think it's the most beautiful way
to understand nihilism but maybe we can
do that in the maximalist i don't know
yeah we'll do it we'll do it over on the
maximum episode let's move on to our
calders real quick if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call 406 219 7839 or email a voice
memo to podcast at theminimalists.com
renee in minneapolis has a question for
us
i lost my husband to cancer when i was
40. i recently remarried
and
i'm in an abusive relationship and going
through a divorce and i feel incredibly
broken and i was wondering if you could
speak to that brokenness and how to move
through that as i begin to rebuild my
life with my children and move back home
renee thanks for the easy softball
question here holy moly
i'm kidding obviously but i'm really
sorry to hear what you're going through
but i'm also grateful to
hear you're going through it to the
other side
i've actually played this message for my
wife who you know previous to me she was
in an abusive
marriage
and um so it really resonated with her
because
there's a whole lot of
despair
hopelessness there's a lot of confusion
when you're going through all this
there's there's too much chaos
and we start grasping for order when
these things happen can you talk about
that with renee yeah i'm so sorry to
hear about what you've gone through
um
the
one of the things about um
psychoanalysis that i find interesting
is
there's there's a very popular view
that we we are all kind of utilitarian
we all want to maximize our pleasure and
minimize our pain and and human beings
we want the best for ourselves you know
even if we do weird things we ultimately
um are trying to pursue our own
self-interest
but i would say the truth is actually
much more complicated that sometimes we
we want our own downfall sometimes we
enter into self-destructive behavior
sometimes we hate ourselves and we we
turn that hatred
against ourselves or sometimes we find
ourselves in difficult environments and
we stay in them because
it reflects something
um that we see in ourselves so i maybe
stay too long in an abusive relationship
because in one sense um
i get to see through the other person's
eyes the way i see myself or whatever
so
always my advice is
so was to break these types of
repetitions
is to really find someone a good
psychotherapist or psychoanalyst um and
to to do this it's the hard work it's a
very courageous work to do to have the
courage to sit once a week or twice a
week and go into those dark parts of
yourself and mourn
because sometimes what happens is when
something
very traumatic happens like the death of
your husband
um
you can't mourn
you can't even mourn his 2p it's too
much it's a trauma it's an event that is
so big you can't put it into words you
can't symbolize it i think in the last
fun last minimalists we talked about i
talked about beeon who said that for a
child they have these experiences of
beta elements which is an event that
happens that the child can't articulate
they can't put into words they can't
speak and so it remains within them it
means and they cry and they act out but
they can't they can't symbolize it
and beyond talks about the role of the
parent as an alpha function and the
alpha function is when the the parent is
able to take the child and sue the child
and put their
trauma their beta element into language
just to help them start to speak it and
to think it and he calls this i love
this because he calls it the alpha
function because what you can hear in
this is the rule of the parent is to
alphabetize
the experience to put into language the
trauma like if we can't alphabetize the
trauma say of the death of of this loved
one
it remains within us
unspoken like a rock like the black hole
that's devastating and will cause it it
comes out it finds a way to speak the
trauma that we cannot speak always finds
a way to speak and it finds a way to
speak through
uh maybe going into a difficult
relationship or being having difficult
relationship with your your kids or
through your bad back or heart disease
it'll always find a way to speak a
symptom as we think we've talked about a
symptom
comes from the word santom and santom
sounds like uh huliman san tom and
french huliman which means a prophet so
your symptom is a prophet that speaks
the truth
and your symptoms
tell you a truth that you cannot speak
so all of this to say that going to a
good psychotherapist is a way sometimes
to
to be able to speak the laws to mourn it
to put it into language and by doing
that
you will become healthier and will be
able to have healthier relationships in
the future so that's i always kind of
that's my advice i mean you maybe
already have a good psychotherapist but
um i'd recommend that and you're welcome
to email me if you want me to help you
find one you know we'll put a link to
peter's website in the show notes
um renee i'm so sorry you're going
through this i'd love to see you we're
going to be out in minneapolis in
february
so
podcast sean if you reach out to her if
she wants to bring her kids or whatever
to the event we're doing a live podcast
minimalism talk but love to give you a
hug as well um the minimalists.com tour
you can find all 20 cities over there or
if you can't make it and you're
listening to this you can find all 20
events as we post them over on patreon
speaking of patreon we're going to check
in with our live stream but for the sake
of time i'm gonna do that during the
maximal episode we'll answer some of
your comments and questions on the
patreon live stream shout out to our
patrons but it is time for our lightning
round this is where we answer your
questions with short shareable less than
140 character
responses you remember this i remember
this whale yeah uh we really just
monitor on a bit and then podcast sean
tweezes out something beautiful he makes
it pithy and yeah you can share it on
social media if you like you can find
all of our minimal maxims in the show
notes or all of them in one place
minimalmaxims.com
looks like we have a question from
elodie oh here by the way i've got a
tweetable thing about this there's okay
there's always a short answer to every
problem and it's always wrong
uh
yes yeah aim into that and before we get
into elite's question it's um
it's
it's always wrong because we're looking
for it to be right yes and i'm sure like
a lot of these things are very complex
and thoughtful but still you know
aphorisms have a place so let's do some
aphorism yeah so and i think aphorisms
are only helpful if they allow us to
unpack them yes if it becomes no this is
the perfect truth in this one sentence
it's unquestionable
then yeah run run away head for the
hills right
let's uh let's hear elodie's question
how do you find new meaning when the
meaning you wanted to give your life is
no longer possible
me first why not okay it doesn't have to
be pithy right away let's talk about
meaning so the search for meaning
[Music]
how do you find new meaning
when the meaning you wanted to give your
life
is no longer possible so you wanted to
find meaning in something maybe it was a
relationship maybe it was a car
maybe it was a home maybe it was the
city you lived in maybe it was your peer
group or your career or your busyness
you know the calendar clutter right
and you wanted to find meaning there
and then you didn't yeah how do you find
new meaning is what she's asking yeah
and okay and so if i was to define
depression in a very succinct way um
depression is often
the loss of desire the loss of meaning
so the more depressed someone is the
more they can't desire anything they
just food is fuel getting out of bed
it's just a chore like there's no
walking is just to get from a to b that
your desire is no longer functioning
and a lot of get overcoming depression
is finding
one's meaning finding a way to find life
and meaning in life
and um
if you believe life is meaningful but
you don't love you can't help but
experience it as meaningless and if
you're in love with something a cause or
whatever even if you don't believe life
is meaningful you can't help but
experience it as meaningful right so
there's
one of the things that's important for
me is if i meet someone or myself and
all meaning is basically gone and by the
way the way that happens often is
there's some object in your life that is
what's called the object cause of your
desire so say you love somebody they're
not just an object that you desire
they're what enables your desire so when
you lose them you don't just lose one of
the ten things you desire in the world
you lose the ability to desire the other
nine things as well right so it's like
your your desire stops functioning it
just dissipates and when that happens
you've lost the object cause of your
desire
um
the the key is and i would say this
thinking of paul tillich and maybe
victor frankl is there's always to be
human is to always have some
over valuation some sense of meaning
something even the most depressed of us
something gets us out of bed at night in
the morning so victor frankel he um he
would ask his his clients
why have you not killed yourself it's a
very rough question to ask and things
like well why are you here and why have
you not killed yourself
and
that question begins to open up that
there's something that got that person
to the room there's something that got
that person to ask that question there's
something and now we're gonna fan that
we're gonna we're gonna try and draw
that out and bring that meaning up again
so sometimes it's almost like well not
how do i find meaning
meaning already is there somewhere and i
just have to start
locating it within my body
and there might not be any meaning of
life but there is meaning in life
yeah
man oh
you could tweet that podcast sean i have
a pithy answer for you maybe we can
unpack it a little bit here a meaningful
life resides at the intersection of love
and devotion
and so that love that you're talking
about you know we i think we often
misunderstand love you know ryan and i
wrote a whole book about it recently was
that the whole idea is like oh yeah i
love my wife but i also love tacos and
it's like well wait a minute we don't
mean the same thing there to love
someone is to see them for who they are
without trying to change them explicitly
now they might cha in fact love tends to
change everyone but the moment we try to
change someone oh i it becomes
conditional love pete i would love you
if you change these seven things about
yourself
uh devotion's the other side of this
what you're really talking about is
fanning that flame there finding
something to devote yourself to it's the
reason
that creativity is often such a pool for
someone an artist or a writer or
filmmaker they they feel
this obsessive devotion to this thing
that becomes meaningful to them doesn't
mean it's inherently meaningful
and so at that intersection of love and
devotion
that's where that's where we tend to
find
meaning even if it isn't there
we tend to bring the meaning there
ourselves and i would say yeah and then
connecting this with the idea of
nihilism and nothing is
so i think i like le cam would talk
about how love
always orients itself to
to a lack or a gap in the other so for
example
um
whenever if i fall in love with someone
because they complete me because i think
they're amazing and they're brilliant or
whatever that's kind of like a romantic
love and it's it's it's fun right yeah
uh lacan once said love is giving what
you do not have to someone who does not
want it
and and what he kind of means by that is
when are you really in love there's
something i don't have like a as in i
feel incomplete and my desire is my lack
you know and i give that to somebody and
they don't really want it because they
want someone who's strong and perfect
and wonderful and great but somehow they
take that lack and they enjoy it and the
reason why i say this is like
whenever an artist loves beauty
they don't just love the beautiful and
they just don't they don't just paint
something and think that they can grasp
the beautiful the beautiful is always
something that is lacking in every
painting it's what it's what inspires
you always so you can never you can
never
create the most the beautiful painting
beauty is something that is always
present and absent at the same time it's
a ghost a ghost is a present absence and
so beauty is like it's there you feel it
you're immersed in your painting but you
can never grasp it when you think you
can grasp it that's not love that's
fanaticism if you think you can grasp
the truth um whereas but the point is
you're not also you can't grasp the
truth but also you can't get away from
the truth because as soon as you talk
about whether there's truth or not we're
assuming truth right we're assuming
meaning so you can't get away from truth
but you also can't grasp it and that's
for me what love is is when you love
someone or a cause it's like
you're with something that you're not
with you grasp something that you can't
grasp it's like the tardis and doctor
who
the person is this fragile freedom this
tiny that's graspable but their inner
world is ungraspable so love both
has and has not and and that the reason
why i say that is so that
you because if you have an orientation
to
this openness of what you do not have
and if that's where you get your
enjoyment
then
you're never dissatisfied because
because you're satisfied in your
dissatisfaction you kind of enjoy so
like that's the whole point of problems
with consumerism is always promise
you'll be happy when you get the object
you know this is going like no there's a
certain not having that's enjoyable
right in fact preferable in many
instances right it's fascinating some of
the words we use here and i've talked
about this previously but i'd love to
run this by you real quick before we
move on in fact i'll skip the right here
right now segment so we can talk about
this but
we use these words like
void and we try to fill the void that
presupposes the void is a bad thing the
lack is a bad thing
but then when you go to montana you
don't say oh my god look at this void we
need to fill this this valley with stuff
or with people or whatever
and no you enjoy
the void and
that the fact that it is missing
something is what makes it beautiful yes
100 and this is like uh not just a kind
of a poetic thing i mean even in the
sciences so you have in biology the
oneness of the biological organism is
called evolution evolutionary theory
which means that there's some sort of
antagonism within biological organisms
in physics it's called indeterminacy the
idea that reality itself has a certain
kind of antagonism
or superpositioning
in politics it's called democracy the
non-oneness of the social body with
itself is called democracy um in
psychoanalysis it's called the
unconscious which is the not at oneness
of the of consciousness with itself and
the reason why i'm bringing out all of
these different
frames is it's
we don't realize how
um
something about lack or
antagonism or contradiction is at the
heart of
love it's a heart of subjectivity but
it's also at the heart of reality itself
and that's what makes everything that's
what gives everything what it is so
there's a way of thinking about nihilism
in that sense
um but the beautiful i said the
beautiful thing about the writers of
nihilism and we're thinking of
kierkegore and nietzsche and dostoevsky
people like that
is that
they're not nihilists
as such what they believe is that
nihilism already is an event it's
already here right we already live but
we're denying it and when we enter into
it and when we actually embrace the
darkness when we have the courage to go
into it fully
then we discover
this new meaning this new
kind of way of life way of being arises
that that has
a type of nothingness
as part of it right it's part of its
very structure yes i am it is required
the nothingness
is what
quote completes us
is maybe
the the being
accepting of the void not in a
prescriptive way like do these three
things and you'll accept the void but
simply understanding that that is part
of it all right the thing that makes us
a space beautiful or a life beautiful is
often the lack yes and this is i mean
this is why i'm in los angeles because
los angeles is the most religious place
in the world right the religious mecca
now when people hear you say that oh
yeah
they are they're going to be bowled over
because what does that mean
i'm thinking of some place in
mississippi must be the most religious
place in the world you mean something
different yeah well just that it's a
place of wholeness and completeness
certainty and satisfaction everybody
here is looking there's prophets in
every corner saying that you can be
whole and complete if you have enough
money you look the right way you have a
certain amount of fame the tyranny of
happiness is everywhere in los angeles
it's quite incredible it's palpable the
um
you know the it's very difficult to be
unhappy to you know you can be you know
to find a space to have the enjoyment of
unhappiness here so
if you if you think of religion
as the philosophy the theory and the
practice of wholeness completeness
oneness
then you know los angeles is this
secular religious mecca
and what's interesting about nihilism or
existentialism in particular is
that this term the death of god is
fascinating so it actually starts with
saint paul the apostle paul is the first
one to use it right he talks about the
death of god
and it's a very bizarre phrase uh and so
this is an occultic setting and i mean
cultic in its traditional sense of a
provisional religious practice right
paul uses this word death of god and
paul doesn't even understand kind of
what he's saying he just says that and
he says this is central to salvation
something about not the death of a god
or a messenger of god the death of god
is something fundamentally existentially
world historical
now nobody really does anything with it
until say luther then luther raises it
to a theological concept
so luther
takes this notion of the death of god
and makes it theological
then he hegel
later he he raises it to the dignity of
philosophy so with hegel this death of
god becomes a philosophical concept
and then with nietzsche he returns to
paul so he's very poor lying he again
says the death of god is an existential
event that we all have to go through
and then freud
develops a technology to help people
confront this so i would that's the kind
of genealogy but what connects all of
these things together
is the idea that disruption distortion
decentering is a central event that we
have to experience an experience of the
death of meaning the loss of all of our
coordinates for why we're here who we
are what we're doing
this event is something that is not just
something we go through but it's
actually something we ought to embrace
it's something central that even every
teenager kind of goes through a mini
death of god you know yes um but there's
something about this event that is so
central
existentially to
the cure
the cure being to a new mood of life a
new mood of being freed from our
libidinal investment and objects that
will satisfy us free from these
libidinally frenetic attempts to be
happy whole and complete
and once we undergo existentially that
event and have the courage to do it
we then enter into
the freedom to and as shizek would say
not the freedom to be happy but the
freedom from happiness it's great to be
free to be happy brilliant let's have
the freedom to pursue what will make us
happy but we also need the space where
we're free from the pursuit of what will
make us happy and that's what happens
through the death of god
pete we got so much more to talk about
alabama you got something for us first
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi this is nancy from iowa
my 91 year old mother who lives in a
senior apartment complex stayed at my
home for christmas we watched some dvds
that my middle lust millennial children
watched years ago these disney movies
musicals and teen comedies were things
that she had never seen before
she laughed a lot and it got me thinking
that most seniors in her complex had not
seen these light-hearted comedies and
musicals either we boxed up all of the
movies my children loved but now stream
instead and donated them to the senior
complex for their weekly movie nights
these movies are now also seen in the
neighboring nursing home
hi my name is chime pasovek i just
wanted to recommend a book called
simplicity parenting by kim john payne
and lisa m ross
and it talks about
similar things about how to parent
simplistically
and i also wanted to recommend waldorf
education w-a-l-d-o-r-f
founded by rudolph spiner
this kind of education
i'm a waldorf teacher and it really
just aligns with a lot of the principles
that you talk about and i think it's a
really
great
source a really good
choice for education if people want to
live aligning with
minimalist ideas
all right y'all let's get to our added
value segment real quick so
before we started recording i was
talking to you about terence malik and
it seems to me there's almost like this
nihilist bent to his films but in such a
beautiful way it's not the dark
nihilism that we think about devolving
into darkness and
quote unquote meaninglessness although
there's great meaning and
meaninglessness interwoven
into his films i just rewatched tree of
life with my wife recently and it sort
of walks people through this
um well the inception the sort of macro
level of the inception of the universe
all the way down to like the birth of a
of a child on this micro level
and it seems to me that there's
simultaneously
great meaning and lack of meaning yes
what do you see when you see a terrence
malek film yeah and we were chatting
about this as you said earlier and i was
saying that malek actually was a
philosopher before a director or at
least he studied philosophy i think
under a guy called herbert dreyfus and
herbert dreyfuss
was one of the few analytic philosophers
who um really got into heidegger's work
so so malek is a high to gary and such
and heidiger's hool thing heidegger was
uh
kind of connected with existentialism
and
and heidegger's whole thing really was
that
we um
have got so caught up in what he calls
the they which is a kyrgyz calls it
leveling but we just care about uh we
think whatever the media tells us to
think we our friends tell us to think we
don't think for ourselves we just give
ourselves over to whatever's there we
it's the great leveling the he heidegger
calls it the they because it's what they
think whenever someone goes oh they
wouldn't like that they
and they is nobody and everybody it's
weird you can never point at who the day
is but they seems to be all
everywhere and newer and it's creating a
villain or other rising in a way that
you know abdicates us from
from the responsibility that's a
terrible word but uh from whatever's
going on outside of us right i mean it's
a great way to advocate responsibility i
mean one of the reasons why kierkegaard
hated
the what he called basically the crowd
or the mass is because you know he says
one individual won't kick somebody to
death but you have a crowd of 100 people
and you'll kick someone to death with
everybody else in other words weirdly
your responsibility as an individual is
dissipated through the day and by the
way he said um whenever he talked about
leveling uh kierkegaard said it's it's
imagine you're in a church and someone
is preaching about slander or something
like that and you're listening and
you're going oh i hope the person beside
me is listening to this because this is
them right he says no one ever hears the
sermon they only overhear it right i
overhear the conversation with somebody
else and he said basically that's like
leveling whenever
we talk about leveling it's always yes i
know people who don't think for
themselves it's never me it's never me
we we never hear that message we always
overhear it but kiragarh says no we we
are all tempted to
to to level to to think the way we're
told um and not think for ourselves so
heidegger's variance that and then
heidegger in his book being in time
which is very malick he uh
he says we've forgotten the question of
being
he says there's lots of beans like
things like we're our world is full of
things
but he says but there is a
almost like a um and this is where
malik's a little bit mystical in his in
his film making but um there's almost
like this sensitivity not to just
individual things that are in the
universe but to the universe itself to
the beauty that is infused within
everything
and so i really see that in mal
especially with the tree of life there's
this meditative almost heideggerian
kind of drawing you into
a kind of detachment from things and an
experience of thingness itself the
beauty of the the reality itself yes
yeah my wife and i when we were watching
it she was she just commented on how it
was the most beautiful
film she'd ever seen and part of it is
because it was almost as though he was
filming being itself yes there was no it
wasn't about doing it wasn't about the
actions and how the plot unfolds there's
no plot there's no script there's none
of that that becomes obsolete in a film
like this it's funny we were talking
about earlier you reminded me of
looking at our neighbor i really hope my
neighbor's listening to this thing that
happens at our live events all the time
where someone comes to the mic can you
tell my husband that he needs to get rid
of his things in the garage
can you tell my wife she has too many
shoes or whatever right and yeah this
manifests in different religions as well
there are whole parables about this by
the way pete's going to be on tour with
us i'm not going to tell you what tour
stop you're going to have to find out
for your own we're coming to 20
different cities we've already done nine
of them the minimalists.com tour it's
the love people use things tour if you
want to see pete at one of those stops
you can there's some context clues there
you can figure out yeah where he will be
don't think you need to be columbo to
work it out but hey we'll say by the way
another one more thing about malik if
you're up for it okay is um so a thinker
i like is a guy gabrielle marcel yeah he
talks about the difference between
problem and mystery a problem is
something that you separate yourself
from and you look at and you can be
objective about a mystery is is a type
of problem in which you're
simultaneously invested right so you
can't take any distance from it because
you're within the very thing you're
thinking and um malik i think does this
very beautifully that the characters are
infused within the wider universe
they're infused it's the the world is
not a problem to be solved but a mystery
to participate in and i think that's a
very malic kind of
vibe well we'll make that our added
value this week podcast john if you can
put a link to tree of life in the show
notes and if you want to check out pete
he has a great podcast called the
fundamentalists i would encourage you to
check that out we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well and his
website you can find all of his social
media his videos his courses
it's just peterrollins.com that's the
one by the way pete we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
causes suffering and how do we avoid it
how do we accurately identify and
address the sources of our depression
when it's not an obvious concern like a
lack of money or friends how do you
appropriately bring up the topic of
depression with someone you're close to
and are worried about plus a million
more questions for peter and the
minimalist well pete and me really and
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives recordings of live
events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists if you want our podcast show
notes on your inbox sign up for our
email list at the minimalist dot com on
behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown and emma the immigrant and the
rest of our team i'm joshua fields
milburn reminding you to love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it